is not just for me this is for every
little girl that looks like me we're
here because we love what we do and we
will never stop doing this because we
really really love it but thank you for
giving me a seat at the table because so
many of us need this we want to be seen
we want to be heard
that is actress Michelle yo winning the
award for outstanding performance in a
lead role at last week's Screen Actors
Guild Awards it's for the film
everything everywhere all at once and
ironically that's also where you can
find the cast and crew these days
winning those major industry Awards
scoring the most Oscar nominations and
covered across the pop culture landscape
our Jamie wax has a story for us good
morning to you Jamie good morning Nancy
that's true and those speeches from that
cast have all been so incredible it all
began with a pair of filmmakers already
known for breaking the mold before
creating this Innovative and
mind-warping Adventure I met up with
them in Los Angeles the duo credit film
and entertainment company a24 for
allowing them to make the movie their
way
co-directors and screenwriters Daniel
Kwan and Daniel scheiner
collectively known as Daniels made their
Mark with distinctively quirky work that
defied typical expectations
what is she doing who's jumping
now they're the creative engine behind
the ears most buzzed about movie
the genre bending sci-fi fantasy
existential comedy drama everything
everywhere all at once starring the
equally buzzed about Michelle yo kiwi
Kwan Jamie Lee Curtis and Stephanie shu
are you both able to enjoy this are you
able to pause and breathe and enjoy how
much people understand connect with
identify with celebrate love your film I
don't know we're trying we're trying I
don't I don't think I don't think I mean
the part you said is the beautiful part
yeah yeah like the fact that people are
celebrating it and love it so much is
like overwhelming I don't think anyone
will ever be able to humanly
um process all of that love so this is
actually
the neighborhood for both of you you
live very close to each other that's
right yeah the pair met while they were
film students at Emerson College and
they quickly figured out they had
complementary interests and talents we
always say that like us being a Duo sort
of just is a window to how all movies
are made uh which is collaboratively you
know that like even if there's one
director one screenwriter one you know
producer they collaborate so intensely
and so closely to make a movie like no
director Makes a Movie by themselves I
also think that having two brains allows
ideas to evolve faster you can kind of
ping pong back and forth in a way where
the iterations
um happen at a pace where you can be way
more inventive the renovation first
gained major attention not for movies
but for music videos including one for a
massive DJ Snake and little John hit
music videos and commercials are an
incredible place for filmmakers to find
their voice and so it feels a little bit
like Film School boot camp where you are
just thrown into a new scenario every
couple months and you just have to see
what you can do within those
circumstances and because of that you
know the filmmakers we were when we
started music videos are completely
different from the filmmakers we are
today the creative genius behind their
music videos got them their first major
feature release or maybe you were as a
special genetically engineered soldier
who was cryogenically frozen and sent
back in time to save me and save all of
mankind Swiss army man which featured a
star whose reaction to the material
shocked even Daniel and Daniel what is
life and well maybe even Daniel
this is you Radcliffe that is this is
your body were you surprised by that
casting and by that opportunity yes I I
think we're surprised anytime someone
says yes to one of our scripts every
time we write something it feels a
little bit like an inside joke that we
can only hope someone will allow us to
make one day and so when Radcliffe said
yes we were like this uh is going to be
incredible but also we were yeah we were
shocked
um but he yeah he didn't just say yes he
said like please
when we first met him the first thing
Radcliffe said was uh can I do my own
stunts and that was like his main
concern was like this sounds fun don't
don't tell me I don't get to do the fun
stuff you know so he did a lot of his
own stuff you want to go home so you can
have
the film was a moderate success and has
attained a solid cult following since
and the two worked on various Television
Productions while developing their dream
project what does she want
no one knows
all we know
is she's looking for you everything
everywhere all at once which they pushed
and waited years for until they got
every detail the way they wanted
including the cast
which Executives weren't exactly
enthusiastic about
Michelle yo Jamie Lee Curtis both of
whom have said they felt like Hollywood
was ignoring them that they were
invisible and they were Typecast
who gave one of the most pure and
energetic and wonderful performances in
film history as a child and then was
completely forgotten by Hollywood
everybody says when I am in charge when
I'm in the director's chair I'm going to
cast good actors you really managed to
do this with this film but how hard was
it it was incredibly hard I would say
the casting was probably one of the
hardest things of the whole process
they're like oh should we try a white
actor you know or should we find other
types of people that might actually
bring in the money and we had to have
some really hard conversations with
people to basically put our foot down
and say no this was written for a
Chinese family
it took a little longer but we
ultimately ended up with
um like an ideal cast The Experiment did
much more than just succeed I thought
you were going to bring your daughter to
help you translate those actors who
seemed to be forgotten in the industry
have dominated award season thank you
thank you
I think if I speak my heart will explode
this is
amazing
so has the movie itself going into the
Oscars with 11 nominations the most of
any film including multiple Noms for
Daniel Kwan and Daniel scheinert what
does it mean to you all now that these
people have Oscar nominations here are
the papers it feels unreal it's like the
ideal thing as a filmmaker that your
four lead actors would all get Oscar
Noms and then they all get to go party
together like everybody gets to come
what a miracle we all get to kind of
like support each other through this
like Adventure that literally none of us
have ever done you know what are you
most looking forward to on Oscar night
uh so like like one of my best friends
is our editor and he's nominated and I'm
excited to just watch it through his
eyes and see how uncomfortable he gets I
think regardless of what we do
regardless of whether or not we win
we're all going to be together
um and I think that's going to be very
fun and special